[Musique]
il y a quatre ans les Bleus remportaient
la Coupe du monde de football en Russie
une victoire déjà célébrée en 1998 en
France les souvenirs mémorables que
cherchent à recréer les clés sous bois à
travers une exposition consacrée à
l'histoire de cette compétition
internationale
à l'occasion du Mondial au Qatar qui
débutera dimanche prochain l'artiste
peintre contemporain lors de Wilmore a
représenté 12 joueurs emblématiques du
sport là nous sommes devant Ronaldo le
Ronaldo portugais parce qu'il y en a un
autre qui est aussi dans cette salle
mais qui est le Ronaldo brésilien
celui-ci donc CCR7 j'ai chaque fois
essayé de trouver pour lui comme pour
les autres une attitude vraiment
reconnaissable du joueur et lui Ronaldo
il est toujours comme ça avant de tirer
les coup francs Benzema justement c'est
quand il est son doigt avec son bandage
pour Mbappé c'est sûr que sa façon de
célébrer les Gaules c'est formidable il
y a que lui qui fait ça avec les bras
croisés et il est sûr de lui de peler à
Ronaldo Lord Wilmore réalise des autant
couleur dite post numérique
le poste numérique en fait c'est
reprendre le contrôle sur la machine ce
qu'on va faire c'est on crée en
numérique l'oeuvre puis après on
réinterprète complètement cette oeuvre
avec de l'acrylique sur toile une
exposition street art et pop habillée de
divers jeux on retrouve des baby-foot
vintage ou encore le légendaire subuteo
pour les enfants c'est bien aussi de
voir que ça existait bien avant et sinon
nous on s'est vraiment amusé à faire
cette expo parce que elle nous ramène en
enfance et à des bons souvenirs quoi on
a fait exposition mais qui lie vraiment
le côté ludique et le côté magique du
foot une rétrospective en peinture qui
durera jusqu'au 4 décembre en espérant
d'ici là ajouter des souvenirs
mémorables à la collection
[Musique]